une canicule qui s'abat sur toute
l'europe même les pays plutôt habitués à
des climats tempérés comme la grande
bretagne et les pays scandinaves sont
accablés par la chaleur
alors est-ce un phénomène ponctuel ou
une des conséquences du réchauffement de
la planète tentative de réponse avec
sophie mais elle est jérôme soûlard
londres n'avait pas connu de telles
températures depuis des lustres 32
degrés pour un climat océanique
c'est suffisamment rare pour que les
habitants se croient à la plage on sait
pourtant que les peaux des britanniques
et le soleil font souvent mauvais ménage
à rome les touristes se font rares sur
la belle place du peuple cuisante sous
le soleil ils vont se réfugier à l'ombre
d'une terrasse mais 30 degrés ce n'est
pas un record pour la ville c'est juste
difficile de tenir le choc
je trouve qu'il fait extrêmement chaud
et la journée c'est parce qu
insupportable de visiter les monuments
qu'on avait prévu voir avec 27 degrés
aujourd'hui à berlin les enfants avaient
envie de se rafraîchir jusqu'à plus soif
mais pas de record rendu en réalité
l'europe affiche des températures
estivales
mais ce n'est pas une surprise pour un
mois de juillet que c'est la
manifestation du réchauffement du climat
on a eu des beaux étaient toutes époques
dans le passé le réchauffement du climat
se traduit plutôt par une lente
progression des températures que l'on
que l'on peut observer sur plusieurs
dizaines d'années
et justement en france comme dans le
reste du monde les températures moyennes
n'ont cessé de monter depuis au moins 30
ans pour la plupart des scientifiques le
responsable c'est le gaz à effet de
serre produit par la combustion des
énergies fossiles le gaz le pétrole le
charbon le gaz carbonique qui se dégage
des cheminées d'usiné des pots
d'échappement modifie la composition de
l'atmosphère c'est comme un couvercle
emprisonnant la chaleur qui se forme au
dessus de nos têtes depuis sentant la
terre s'est réchauffée d'un degré mais
ce n'est rien à côté de ce qui est en
train d'arriver
si rien ne change nous allons gagner de
2 à 4 degrés d'ici la fin de ce siècle
de grands parce que quand on dit
réchauffement c'est un raccourci
en fait c'est tout tout ce qui change en
climat le cycle de l'eau les pluies la
répartition détruit la ripelle la
fréquence des pluies fortes ou des
périodes de sécheresse tout ça risque de
changer
et là on est encore plus dans dans le
brouillard si on peut dire que pour le
réchauffement proprement parler l'une
des conséquences immédiates du
réchauffement climatique c'est aussi que
les températures de nuit ne baissent
plus autant qu'avant dans le constate
mais on peut pas encore entièrement
l'expliqué la science du climat réserve
encore de nombreux mystères